well we've been having fun introducing
christian to you the newest member of
our eight news now team he'll be here
every day with ted night four o'clock
all right christian
why don't you let the viewers know where
you were born and raised where you grew
up
well i'm you know born and raised in
southern california in san diego and
i've
basically lived from coast to coast so
you know i've
i've lived in different cities but i i
don't know i got to tell you
san diego is is a very nice place to
live
it really is yes but here is home
christian
yes and christian has actually you're
you're
actually you're not new to las vegas
he's actually lived here before
he's come back like i have and a lot of
other people right many many moons ago
no i i used to work here
many years ago but as you guys know
working in in news we
bounce a lot a lot yeah i went from las
vegas to philadelphia i went to the east
coast i went to philly
to new jersey back to the bay area to
california and now i'm back in las vegas
and
i'm so happy to be back it's so nice the
city is just amazing the people are so
friendly
uh and like you i mean like we were
talking about earlier no snow
so yes except stays up in the mountain
and your money goes a lot further here
you know all the reasons you moved here
from california
so do the viewers my goodness here is
home and here is wonderful so we are so
glad to have you christian
and he's also taken over our station's
instagram for the entire day and evening
so to find out more about them you can
go check that out and on our website
where we do some kind of rapid fire
questions as well
like what's the first thing christian
does when he gets up in the morning
how he likes his steak just some random
stuff out there folks kind of fun
i want to know that stuff okay go check
it out let's do it